[Musik]
das macht ihm spaß
direkt ran an den schaltkasten timo ochs
hatte einfach keine lust mehr auf
vorlesungen an der uni und mathe pauken
elektronik interessiert ihn hier darf er
mit dem meister ein schaltkasten für die
komplette elektrik in einem krankenhaus
bauen
also ich habe energie gebäude umwelt
technik angefangen zu studieren aber
schnell gemerkt dass das sehr
theoretisch ist dass man unglaublich
viel verschiedene fächer dafür braucht
die mich jetzt nicht im speziellen
interessiert haben ich habe schnell
gemerkt dass mich elektrotechnik sehr
interessiert und habe dann beschlossen
den weg über eine ausbildung zu gehen
der betrieb hat sich gefreut drei
lehrstellen blieben in diesem jahr
unbesetzt
es gab einfach zu wenig bewerben das
familienunternehmen baute elektroanlagen
für unternehmen behörden und andere
öffentliche einrichtungen
der betrieb ist ständig gewachsen gern
würde die chefin noch mehr elektroniker
einstellen
der studienabbrecher war für sie ein
glücksgriff
das ist einfach schon gesetzt da ruhiger
und weiß schon den weg den er gehen will
nachdem er das studium abgebrochen hat
suchte er sich jetzt einen neuen weg wo
er dann zurecht kommt und klar kommt was
die jüngeren noch nicht genau wissen
die machen ihre ausbildung und sind noch
ein bisschen um ruhiger vom wesen her
der betrieb liegt vor den toren von
münster einer studentenstadt
eigentlich gibt es hier genügend
potenzial für auszubildende
doch die meisten abiturienten wollen
studieren aber jeder vierte student
bricht im schnitt bundesweit sein
studium ab genau das macht sich die
agentur für arbeit zu nutze
sie will diese jungen fachkräfte
abwerben sowie julia opgen rhein zum
beispiel die 27 jährige lässt sich heute
beraten
hier geht es ihm endlich immer noch sehr
unentschlossen zu ende
kein master und brinkmann alternative
und vielleicht neues berufsfeld was mir
er legt wo ich eher zu richten
nach sieben jahren hat sie ihr
lehramtsstudium abgebrochen
eine erleichterung ich dachte schon ich
kann es nicht dann habe ich die
hausarbeiten vor mir hergeschoben
klausuren vor mir hergeschoben wollte
nicht mehr zu den dozenten und sehr
lange gebraucht um zu merken dass ich
einfach mit dem studium unzufrieden bin
und dass mich die perspektive stört die
am ende steht also dass leser werden und
das ist jetzt so vorgezeichnet ist fing
an mich zu stören weil ich innerlich
gemerkt habe es ist nicht meins und dass
ich damit nicht glücklich wäre wenn ich
das jetzt 40 jahre lang mache in welche
richtung jetzt die alte jetzt will sie
sich zur software entwicklerin ausbilden
lassen
die berufsberaterin kennt viele solcher
fälle jahrelang etwas studieren was
einem eigentlich doch nicht gefällt aber
im laufe der jahre danach hat man viel
besseres bild zu seinen eigenen
interessen und stärken und sind da auch
mutiger bereiche für sich zu erschließen
die mehr ihrer persönlichkeit und ihren
interessen entsprechen
timo zeit endlich feierabend in
anderthalb jahren macht er seine prüfung
und ist ein elektroniker bereut er den
entschluss sein studium abgebrochen zu
haben
eigentlich gar nicht weil ich viele
freunde hat die studenten sind und ich
weiß dass sie halt auch ihr programm
haben sage ich mal aber da bin ich
überhaupt nicht neidisch drüber und ich
sehe halt dann viele mal am schreibtisch
sitzen und lernen und so wenn ich dann
schon frei auf und das ist dann für mich
auch immer eigentlich überhaupt kein
problem das sie dann studenten sind und
ich halt nicht oder nicht mehr seine
freunde die noch studenten sind müssen
vielleicht am wochenende lernen die
moritat frei und verdient schon sein
eigenes geld als meister wird er
außerdem später kaum weniger verdienen
als seine studierten kollegen